that's what i
that's my issue is i'm always trying to
perfect everything to be great at
everything and it's just
i suffer because it's impossible it's
impossible to be great at everything to
be perfect at everything to be perfect
at anything it's it's there's no such
thing and yet with me if i'm not great i
feel like i failed
and that is a terrible way to live your
life and i have
started to get better about it i'm
starting you know i've been going to
therapy and working on myself but how do
you deal with that so what do you what
do you work on what do you do that first
of all you don't you don't give off that
vibe just so you know and i think that's
well i can't or i won't work if
no one wants to see someone who's just
you know like that but um i try to be
honest about it on this podcast i try to
no that's that's brave i like that um
what do i do to battle that um
one of the things that i that someone
once asked me to do and i thought it was
really useful was
make a list mentally physically write
things down i write in a journal that's
like physical because i think that i
think it does something different than
typing
um actually being able to like write
with your hand and then see it in a
paper and tactile world which we're
losing um but i digress someone told me
make a list of the people that you
admire
and what you admire about them
and
and how many of those reasons are
because they're perfect
like what are the things that make your
skin you know you know when you watch
something or you hear something or you
see something and it just kind of makes
your skin feel alive and you know that
you're in the presence of realness
whether that's like a concert you go see
um we just saw bonnie there in asheville
it was so beautiful or it's um or or
it's a stage production or it's someone
standing up for someone else's rights or
it's i don't know it's just those things
that i'm getting them now there's like
those feelings in your body where you're
like i'm in the i'm in the presence of
greatness
very rarely is that greatness perfect
very rarely does that greatness look or
smell or seem like how you think you
should be in order to be perfect and so
if we started actually giving props and
love and admiring the things that give
us that feeling rather than the things
that look a certain way or seem a
certain way
i think we'd have a better
connection to what is actually and what
is actually perfect than using
quotation thinkers